hey guys it's Jan here I've just been to
see Batman V Superman dawn of justice
and I've got lots of thoughts on the
movie but just before I get to those I
want to let you know about a great
giveaway I've got for a very cool Batman
V Superman dawn of Justice the art of
the film hardback book it'll be on my
Batman V Superman easter egg video so
make sure you subscribe and I'll add a
link to that video here when it's ready
okay the big screen schedule that DC set
themselves with solo movies and team ups
like Justice League is very ambitious
and before seeing Batman V Superman I
did wonder if DC was trying to run
before they could walk and whether they
were rushing too much to keep up with
Marvel who took more time to build up
their big screen Empire with a shedload
of movies and a massive universe of
characters and worlds however now I've
seen Batman V Superman i feel that DC's
ambition looks like it could pay off
rather nicely in bv SI successfully
introduced beneful x batman and they
give us a taste of what we can expect
from gal gadot's Wonder Woman movie too
there's certainly a hell of a lot to fit
into this film what with all the
elements we expect of a Superman movie
and a Batman movie having to have their
moment not to mention the pointers to
various members of the Justice League
which are somewhat shoehorned in still
DC's world and franchise building feels
like it's off to a decent start and I
have my fingers crossed that will
continue in future films I can
definitely get on board with Ben
Affleck's believably world-weary
rendition of the Dark Knight and it'll
certainly help wipe his daredevil a
little further from my memory in fact a
flex presence on screen puts henry
cavill's superman firmly in the shade
and i look forward to seeing batfleck in
a solo movie along with more of Jeremy
Irons sardonic turn as Alfred as the gal
Godot I enjoyed her appearance as wind a
woman and it certainly piqued my
interest for her solo outing next year
but when it comes to Jesse Eisenberg's
Lex Luthor I'm not a fan it feels like
he's taking his social network turn as
Mark Zuckerberg and dialed the tix up to
11 in the misguided hope of pulling off
a performance as memorable as Heath
Ledger's Joker sadly for us he does not
cut sukkah definitely have been made to
the film's two and a half hour runtime
including one especially ridiculous
cameo a plot holy subplot and in
deviously repeated flashback that feels
like the director Reuters shouting to us
hey idiots I know you've got the memory
of a goldfish so here's that bit you saw
earlier that you need to remember now to
understand this bit having said that the
script by our go screenwriter Chris
Terrio and David s Goyer mostly moves
along well and they deal with Batman's
already super familiar origin story very
neatly indeed and I really like the way
the film cleverly links back to the
events of Man of Steel giving us a
completely new angle on what happened
but overall I felt that the reasons for
Batman's dislike of Superman were better
established in the reasons to Superman's
dislike of Batman there's no denying
that bbs is a dark and gritty film but
compared to Man of Steel you can sense
they've made a concerted effort to
include more humor in the script some of
those efforts pay off nicely though a
number failed to land just as they did
in supermans first outing but let me be
clear on this I do not need or want DC
to replicate Marvel's formula but
remember that even amongst the darkness
of Nolan's Batman movies there was still
a spark of wit there are some incredible
and exciting action sequences throughout
the movie and director Zack Snyder takes
his time to build up to the big battle
advertised in the main title which for
Musa plus is allowed time to build both
tension and the characters antagonism
rather than racing to the main event too
quickly props to stunt coordinators
Damon kara and Tim Rigby in their stunt
teams for their work throughout as well
as sound editor Scott hacker in his
department especially for the standout
work during the action sequences how
much you enjoy a certain part of the
action will depend on what you think of
holy CG creations that feel like riffs
on the Hulk meets king kong by Godzilla
and Ray Harryhausen's creatures bbs is
pretty quickly cut by editor David
Brenner who keeps the pace up nicely
through most of the movie and there's
some interesting use of slow mo going a
few scenes it gets taken a bit too far
still I was glad that this time there
wasn't so much shaky cam or the
incessant zooming in zooming out zooming
back in again that we had in Man of
Steel which at times in that movie made
me feel like I was watching an episode
of 24 in terms of the look of the film
and it sets I can't fault the work of
production designer Patrick Tatopoulos
art director Troy Sizemore or set
decorator Carolyn Luke's and their teams
who
I should create distinctive environments
for Batman Superman and lex luthor one
of my biggest folk birds about BBS so is
the music it's incredibly overbearing
and bombastic and feels like it's
constantly trying to take over each
scene it's in especially during dramatic
moments and action sequences the scores
by Hans Zimmer who scored Nolan's Batman
trilogy and junkie XL who compose the
scores from Mad Max fury road and
Deadpool as fantastic as their work is
on other movies what they did here just
does not work to the point where it
endlessly batters you about the head
taking you out of the movie and I really
hope they change things up for future DC
outings so to sum up Batman V Superman
dawn of Justice is a super-powered super
PAC defer that brings plenty to the
comic book movie table is it perfect no
of course it's not far from it but it's
also far from being a disaster and
there's definitely much to like about it
not least Zac Snyder and cinematographer
Larry Fong's visual flair some
incredible action sequences ben
affleck's batman and gal gadot's Wonder
Woman in fact I much preferred it to Man
of Steel overall bbs gives me hope for
the nascent DC extended universe fingers
crossed that they live up to that Batman
V Superman dawn of Justice gets 3 out of
5 flicks now I'd love to know what you
think about mum v superman do you think
DC got it right and are you excited for
the Justice League and Wonder Woman solo
movie let me know in the comments below
coming up next will be my Batman V
Superman full easter egg video my
spoiler review of the top 5 WTF moments
in the film and some cool
behind-the-scenes secrets about the
making of the movie those videos and
more will all be in my Batman V Superman
playlist which you'll find a link to
here and you might also want to check
out my daredevil season 2 videos with
easter eggs top moments and review here
too thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
you